[Music]
look what I become
okay so today we have a very uh unique
podcast here uh we have some friends
here we were talking earlier to discuss
the importance of the MBA and the
greatest players of all time that's what
we're going to talk about it's it has
nothing to do with faith nothing to do
with religion no discussion but in on a
uh seriousness I've been looking forward
to this for a while
um I know it's it's a bit of a sensitive
setup to to have it like this we
discussed it was supposed to be a
different uh couple different
individuals brothers from your end
coming in and then Muhammad hijab and I
had a call together we had a zoom he had
some challenges and I got to give shout
out to Eddie uh the dean show he's here
with us as well but he's sitting outside
uh to have the discussion for us to be
here together Robert uh I respect all of
you for coming out truly I respect you
for coming on my outcome I want to First
share with you and the audience what my
outcome of this is
so as a father of four I'm a little bit
concerned on what's going on with the
country in America I escaped Iran we
went to Germany at a refugee camp then
we came here
and I have four kids and I love America
I think this is an incredible Nation
it's changed my life uh but some of the
things that's going on right now it's
kind of weird it's strange it's not
normal it doesn't seem normal to me and
I have friends I'm a Christian myself
I'm a non-denominational Christian
people know that's my position but I
have a lot of friends that are Muslims I
have Scientologist friends I have Mormon
friends I have Jews you know who are
here with us as well uh so I wanted to
bring this up because we're going to
discuss a few different things today
number one is the differences in the
religion of Christianity and uh Muslim
will discuss that and then uh we'll
discuss the enemy who is the enemy to
Christians who is the enemy to Muslims
and then we're gonna share who are
common enemies are and some funny
questions I want to ask you we'll have
some levity here as well to enjoy the
discussion and then there'll be an
opportunity for you guys to also discuss
with each other this is not a debate
this is a discussion of course there's
going to be moments of debate and you
given your point of view that that's
going to happen no matter what naturally
the setting is where that is going to
happen but I want to make sure everybody
knows that's my outcome I think there is
an area where if we can find common
enemies the enemies greater than we
think at the end that's my outcome but
with that being said let me properly
introduce everybody so first
we have uh Danielle uh uh uh
I said it seven times properly and then
whenever we're on I can't so Daniel
hakiraju attended Harvard University
where he majored in physics and
philosophy he's a Sunni Muslim debater
who specializes in debating anti-muslim
figures he founded muslimskeptic.com and
teaches Islam at mosques and
universities around the world thank you
for being here thank you Patrick and he
has a book here as well the modernist
menace to Islam we'll put the link below
as well Rob so if people want to pick it
up they can and then we have Jake
brancatella right who is here with us I
was telling him early I'm used to that
last name more often with some of the
friends we interview he is the Muslim
metaphysician is a convert to Islam he
holds a ba in philosophy and is
currently studying for a masters in
philosophy and theology Jake primarily
debates Christians and atheists and is
an active member of the Muslim debate
initiative then we have brother Rashid
here to my I write
he wrote a book called the ideology
behind Islamic terrorism a Moroccan
Christian convert and the host of the
daring questions television program
where he discusses Christianity and
engages with Islamic Theology and
religious topics brother she thanks you
for being here thank you for having me
and last but not least Robert Spencer
American author and commentator known
for his writings of Islam
counterterrorism and his involvement
with the organizations like Jihad watch
the most popular blog within the counter
Jihad movement he's also written the
truth about Muhammad he's written a
critical Quran and also his latest book
that's I think is that the critical
Quran you have out here and he's read a
few other things Rob again once again
thank you for being here as well so what
I'd want to do is before we get started
you know and I have some comments and
questions here if if you you know just
for some of the audience that maybe they
don't know the whole story we can start
off with anyone on how you came about
your current position right now if you
can take 30 seconds to a minute giving
your background and it will go from
there so we're going to start off with
you Robert how did you go I've read your
story of course I know your background I
watch a lot of commentary on you how did
you become the person that you are today
well you know how one thing leads to
another and I was uh fascinated with
Islam in the Islamic World from a very
early age because uh my grandparents
actually uh are from the Ottoman Empire
they were Greek Orthodox Christians in
what is now turkey and were exiled
during World War One for not converting
to Islam
when I knew them actually my grandmother
was the only person besides Barack Obama
who said that the who I knew who said
that the call to prayer the Islamic call
to prayer was the most beautiful sound
that she had ever heard and she was
would tell me stories about growing up
in turkey and how wonderful it was and
how beautiful the land was how wonderful
the people were and so on and so then I
would ask the inevitable question I was
you know five years old or whatever well
then why are you here why did you leave
and then they would clam up and not tell
me so this just made me more interested
started to study it consulted with
people ended up Consulting with some
people in the 90s about these issues and
then after 9 11 was asked to write a
book and now I've written 27 books
mostly on this issue and I I watch you
where you you have a certain level of a
true 100 belief in in what you're
talking about we'll get into here in a
minute and I'm sure I'm sure we'll get
more about that brother Rasheed how
about yourself yes I grew up uh in
Morocco my dad was an Imam for a mosque
and I was a Muslim like every other
Moroccan at age of 12 I was listening to
a radio program that's when I heard
about Christianity and I started
comparing between Islam and Christianity
I was fascinated with the person of
Jesus in the gospels and I was shocked
with the life of Muhammad when I
compared it to the life of Jesus then I
converted at age of 16 17.
then I had to leave my family actually
they rejected me I lived as a homeless
for two years and I had to live
underground with the Moroccan Church the
converse until
2003 2005 I had to flee the Country 2005
you have to flee the country yeah okay
and we'll get into your stories about a
little bit more when topics come up uh
uh uh uh Jake how about yourself what's
your story what's your background yeah
so I was uh raised the Roman Catholic uh
my entire family is Roman Catholic up
until today
um I personally never really believed in
the religion primarily because the
theology never really made much sense to
me uh As I Grew Older in my late teens
and going into University years
I naturally you know the mind starts to
think about the deeper questions in life
what's the purpose of life does God
exist what religion is true and so I
went on this search and eventually found
the path of Islam primarily because I
believe that it's the only religion
today that truly supports pure
monotheism I know that Christians and
maybe we'll get into this and the
discussion claimed to be but I found
doctrines like the Trinity and
Incarnation to be completely uh
incoherent and found problems with them
and the Islamic Narrative of there being
one and only true God uh that is worthy
of worship and that he sent prophets and
Messengers
um with this consistent method message
throughout time uh was very inviting to
me and fit with my natural disposition
and I became a Muslim in my early 20s
about 10 years ago and been Muslim ever
since fantastic thank you for that
Daniel how about yourself yeah my
background is my parents uh came from
Iran they're both from Shiraz I was born
in the U.S actually and was raised here
in Houston Texas and I love my parents
um and they raised me like an Iranian
had a strong Iranian Persian identity as
I was in high school and then College I
started to become more religious like
learning about my background from my
grandparents for example from my dad and
I just became more religious started
practicing Islam I became Sunni so I'm
from a Shiite background I became Sunni
and uh in college I went to Harvard
University there was a lot of pressure
on Muslims at that time because of like
the war on terror counter-terrorism
efforts and there was this effort to
liberalize Islam and to say that
additional Islam or the Quran or the
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him this
is their teachings are not consistent
with Modern Life with modernism and
liberal secularism and this posed a
conflict for me like how do I reconcile
a traditional Islam with liberalism
secularism and these modern ideologies
so I went and studied philosophy and I
became critical of these ideologies like
modern liberal secularism humanism
atheism these isms and and that's you
know the title of my book basically
they're a subtitle my book is critiquing
these isms that I believe and through my
study they're destroying Humanity not
just Islam but just all of humanity is
under threat from these isms that are
destroying Human Society I hope we can
talk about that today by dedicated my
career basically to promoting this
message teaching Islam teaching how
Islam solves many of the problems and
difficulties that all people face in
society not just Muslims I love that
okay thank you for that again a
gentlemen thank you for sharing your
background so let's get right into it
Robert your channel what is your biggest
challenge with the religion religion of
Islam what's your biggest challenge with
it you mean the biggest the biggest
difficulty I see in it I would say the
biggest difficulty because to me I see
it from a few different places right one
there's faith meaning none of us have
gone to heaven to see what heaven's
going to look like we're all taking a
risk all of us here are taking a risk uh
either we're all going to be right
either we're all going to be wrong or
either one of us is going to be right
meaning one group's going to be right
and the other is going to be wrong but
we don't know that's Faith that's prayer
of course we've had great experiences in
life to say I had a connection with God
I had a moment with that that and then
that's individual to us right so to me
it's Faith it's religion it's enemies
it's common enemies it's the challenges
that's going on in in the world
specifically with America has been for
the longest time the greatest country in
the world what is affecting that and
then there's a few other things I will
talk about into as well so but for me
it's more from the standpoint of when
when you when you've you've said you've
read the Quran dozens of times you have
you've studied it you've written about
it you've talked about it even I think
the government used two of your books in
2011 that wire talked about right I
don't know what the two books were I
think one of them was about Prophet
Muhammad and uh you know so your
background you've been in this world
what is your biggest challenge and
differences with the religion of Islam
well you know probably the main thing is
the sanctification of violence and the
idea that
God will bless and even calls upon the
Believers to commit acts of violence
under certain circumstances like Rasheed
here is an ex-muslim and so under
Islamic law as it's traditionally and
classically formulated he would be put
to death Muhammad said anybody who
changes his religion killed him and it's
still the position of all of the schools
of Islamic jurisprudence Sunni and Shia
that the apostate should be put to death
now obviously this is not something that
means that every apostate has to always
go around watching himself because it
you have to have somebody who's willing
to do that but those who do do it they
think well now I have done something
that Allah has commanded and he will
bless me for doing it and me myself
because I was standing up for the
freedom of speech 2015 Pamela Geller and
I put on in Texas a Muhammad Art Exhibit
and cartoon contest and it was actually
we featured a lot of classic Shiite
Persia in art depicting Muhammad as well
as contemporary art that is was from a
more critical standpoint and a couple of
jihadis came from Phoenix
key members actually of the Islamic
community center of Phoenix one of them
was featured in a recruitment video for
them and they tried to kill us
and so I actually would be also under a
death sentence just for
drawing Muhammad and for sponsoring
people who do which I did not in order
to cause gratuitous insult but to defend
the freedom of speech and freedom of
expression which is the foundation of
any genuinely free Society Danny what
would you say to that what's your
response to that
yeah so just uh a few points here number
one it's interesting how we want to talk
about Islam as a religion but we the
religion is 95 like what Jake mentioned
it's about worshiping God being devoted
to a righteous way of life loving your
neighbors taking care of your parents
that's what 95 percent of Islam is about
yes there are criminal punishments which
we're going to discuss there is
um Conquest there is war Theory there's
all of this in Islam but it's
interesting how when a conversation is
about Islam we focus on that five
percent instead of the 95 of what Islam
is about we don't see this kind of
double standard with like Christians so
if you have someone like Matt Walsh Matt
Walsh is a traditional Christian there's
slavery in the Bible there's punishment
for blasphemers in the Bible there's
killing of Heretics in the church
tradition there's no discussion of that
with Matt Walsh right or Ben Shapiro
there is killing of blasphemers in the
Hebrew Bible there is you know
punishments for apostasy in the talmud
there's no discussion of that with Ben
Shapiro you can talk about you know
other values and that's what the
discussion focuses on but the
islamophobic narrative is just lasering
in on these specific topics which is
fine we can discuss that but I just want
to note the double standard so the other
framing of this whole discussion that I
want to put out here though is that I
want I'm wondering like this standard of
oh there should be no punishment for
um blasphemy for example let's just put
that out there there should be no
punishment for mocking and insulting a
religion attacking people's values is
that coming from a Christian perspective
is that coming from a traditi is that
coming from the church tradition is that
coming from the Bible because when we
look at the Bible we see in Leviticus we
see in Deuteronomy that blasphemers
should be put to death even if you
entice you know the Bible says if you
entice uh like your son or your daughter
or your wife entices you to worship
other than God then have no mercy put
them to death without due process
mentioned without any kind of court or
tribunal the husband or the father
should just immediately put them to
death without Mercy that's what the
Bible says so when Robert wants to
criticize Islam I'm wondering is that
criticism on the basis of the Bible is
it on the basis of the church tradition
or is this a liberal secular modernist
critique of Islam so I want to know am I
debating or discussing with two
Christians or two atheists or two
liberal secularists like that's a
clarification that we need
yes
this is a very important clarification
and there are a couple of distinctions
that have to be made one is all of your
examples from Christianity are from Old
Testament law which if you had studied
Christianity you would know there's no
sect of Christianity no school of of
Christian thought no tradition within
Christianity that holds That Old
Testament law applies to Christians
for all time as a matter of fact it
never did apply even in Judaism after
the destruction of the temple in 70 A.D
the rabbis redefined Judaism so that
even they don't teach that those
punishments have ongoing validity so
you're talking about something that is
that nobody in mainstream Judaism or
Christianity thinks is valid today
versus something that unfortunately all
too many Muslims do think is valid today
and the bringing up of ancient
historical wrongdoing is all very well
and there's certainly a place for that
I've got no interest in denying any of
the misdeeds of Christians throughout
history but the problem that we have in
Islam is that these passages of the
Quran that are problematic passages of
Muhammad's Traditions that are
problematic they are still considered to
be in force by very large numbers of
Muslims such that all the major
terrorist groups around the world are
Islamic groups and you don't have
Christian terrorist groups saying Jesus
is Lord and blowing people up there's a
reason for that and the reasons have to
do with the interpretative traditions in
both religions
can I come go ahead please yeah so I
would ask Robert a very simple question
that I think gets at what the real issue
actually is do you believe that it's
inherently immoral for an apostate to be
put to death
do I believe that it's inherently
immoral for an apostle it's inherently
immoral well I know this is some kind of
trap but in any case no it's I don't see
any honesty on your part that's all you
can always have honesty on my part
everything I tell you is the truth okay
and the fact is that yeah I don't know I
I tell you the truth I haven't thought
about it okay if you haven't thought
about it well you're writing all these
books on Islam Today right and you don't
even know if this is inherently immoral
that's quite sure I would say that I
don't think that it's moral to put the
apostate to death so it's immoral as it
comes to my books about Islam I'm just
reporting on what Islamic clerics and
the Islamic tradition teaches about
passages like when Muhammad says if
somebody changes his religion kill him
so yeah but if you look for example in
chapter 4 verse 89 of the Quran in the
critical Quran where it says if they
turn Renegade then come and kill them
wherever you find them then I give
Islamic authorities who actually say
that this should be done and that is
something people need to know
now whether you're talking about in the
ideal Society you have apostates put to
death I don't think so because I believe
in the freedom of conscience and the
idea that the of the Dignity of the
human person which is a Christian
concept that's not in Islam you have an
Islam you know the unbelievers are the
most vile of created beings according to
chapter 6.
where is this Christianity all people
are equal in dignity as made in the
image of God and so in in that sense I
would say no I don't think it is so is
it inherently immoral yes or no yes or
that it is it is so when the Bible when
Deuteronomy since you like to quote the
Quran when the Bible says this in
Deuteronomy 13 6 if your brother the son
of your mother your son of or your son
of your daughter the wife of your bosom
or your friend who as as your own soul
secretly entices you saying quote let us
go and serve other gods which you have
not known neither you nor your fathers
of the Gods of the people which are all
around you near to you or far from you
from one end of the Earth to the other
end of the Earth You shall not consent
to him or listen to him nor shall your
eye pity him nor shall you spare him or
conceal him but you shall surely kill
him your hand shall be first against him
to to put him to death death and
afterward the hand of all the people and
you shall Stone him with stones until he
dies because he sought to entice you
away from the Lord your God who brought
you out of the land of Egypt from the
house of bondage so all Israel shall
hear and fear and not again do such
wickedness as this among you so when let
me let me finish the passage so when
you're loving God Jesus Christ who you
believe is God who revealed the Old
Testament and revealed this as a law for
the people and you said that it's
inherently immoral for the punishment of
apostasy to be death then you are
charging your own God and supposedly
loving Jesus with immorality not at all
if you don't see that contradiction and
hypocrisy they really do much for you
well it's not in the least contradictory
or hypocritical because that is God
actually
ordering something which is wrong for
that now the question here is whether
the Muslims when they put people to
death for apostasy today are likewise
authorized by God in some direct manner
now obviously yes the question is and
it's not inherently immoral it just
matters what is the correct religion and
whether or not God is actually revealing
it yeah if you study the Old Testament
you will actually find that there's a
great deal of discussion about passages
like that and whether they are actually
commands by God whether they were
understood by the faithful
interpretations by the faithful the
evolving understanding in the Old
Testament and the new and in Jewish and
Christian tradition is something that
unfortunately is absent in Islam such
that in Jewish and Christian tradition
you have the understanding of the
Dignity of the human person that
ultimately made people realize that
putting people to death for apostasy was
not something that was acceptable but
the idea that it was a localized command
at some point or understood to be such
that is not the same thing as people
nowadays thinking they are the executors
of the wrath of Allah because Muhammad
says if anybody changes his religion
kill him and the Quran says that you can
soothe your your your heart by fighting
the unbelievers and so on so Robert can
we hear my brother Rasheed for one
brother what's on your mind because this
is concerns me do you believe I should
be put to death I believe that the
punishment for apostasy in a correct
Islamic state is death I believe that
that's the correct you'll finish let me
just respond sir I believe that that is
the correct punishment which has been
revealed by God both in the Quran and
the Bible and for Robert to turn around
I asked you let me let me finish I asked
you do you believe I should be killed
today and I answered you sir yes or no I
answered you yes or no
in a proper Islamic jurisprudent uh
jurisdiction yeah an Islamic Nation all
of the laws of Islam and the Sharia as
revealed by God should be applied so if
we were in that kind of state would you
do including including I'm not the one
with the proper due process with a
proper court hearing just like any
nation of laws the the laws of the
Sharia should be applied including the
death penalty for not only apostates but
also blasphemers you didn't answer me
yes or no we didn't yes we didn't yeah
so I should be killed we did answer I
deserve to be killed because I left
Islam and became a Christian According
to Islamic law an apostate like you
would be killed yet okay thank you and
of course okay let me let me let me this
is femur this is a fallacy Roberts like
you want to see it's not you have it too
it's a fallacy let us discuss this
because
let me finish let me finish let me to
finish please condemn Jesus you thank
you Jesus
saying you're lying about that let me
finish that's what happened
and then I'll come to you go you're
converted from Christianity to Islam
your life is not in their threat here in
the U.S I converted from from Islam to
Christianity my life is under debt
that's the difference between
Christianity and Islam yes I got a
question for you guys I'm a data guy I'm
a finance guy how many Christians have
died uh gone from being Christian to
Muslim how many Muslims have actually
been killed or died gone from being a
Muslim to a Christian there's no data on
that because these kinds of things are
not recorded they're not considered
crime there should be right I mean
shouldn't you shouldn't there even if
there's some stories to be able to say
you know XYZ individual I have stories I
have one in Mauritania who was condemned
for to be executed we just got him out
to Paris because we negotiated with the
government there I have people right now
in Libya they are under death penalty in
Libya I have people who got killed in
Jordan for example because I do my show
people contact me I have people who got
killed in Jordan their parents killed
them because of they became uh
Christians from from a Muslim background
we have people in different places in
the world in the Muslim Community they
kill them and if they get if they get to
flee that's the best outcome I got a
question so so the while I'm studying
this there's also Daniel said something
very interesting where the the
guidelines of
Quran is based on the jurisdiction of
the government meaning where you live
the religion is follow whatever the laws
are of that Nation meaning you can
correct me I'm just giving you what my
what I've looked into does this mean
these rules apply no matter where you
live is that across the board or is it
it's more stricter in certain Muslim
nations than other Christian nations
Islam is to be applied died Forever on
every place since the time of Muhammad
until today so Muslims are just seeking
to be a majority one day and the if
Muslims are majority today these two
brothers will witness my killing in
front of people and they will be happy
cheering the crowds that I was killed so
Islam us became majority Muslim today
you would be killed I will be killed
Sharia is to be applied everywhere every
time and that's the biggest difference
with Christianity because Jesus came and
he stopped the Old Testament he stopped
every he he didn't Stone the lady who
committed adultery he didn't he said in
in the law tooth for tooth and he said
no you turn the other cheek Jesus
stopped the Old Testament they don't
have a new testament in Islam they have
worse than the Old Testament they have
something that Muhammad never corrected
so today we have to do Jihad today we
have to kill the apostate today we have
to to kill the person who who doesn't
pray even a Muslim if he stops praying
if he stops praying he should be killed
if he has no excuse he should be killed
according to it I'd like to give them a
chance to respond Daniel what would you
because the point I think you were
making was how that maybe doesn't apply
based on what the countries are and then
he makes a good point about saying but
if U.S eventually becomes majority
Muslim then that could be the criteria
that we have to follow in U.S what's
your response to that yeah so there are
a lot of inaccuracies in what he's
talking about I want to reframe the
issue because he's saying that his life
is in danger but the lives of Muslims
are in danger under a secular liberal
hegemony and I know that some of the
viewers might not be following while I'm
discussing but look at the war on terror
or even look at me personally or Jake
but I say things that are contrary to
liberalism I critique and criticize
liberal secularism and what is liberal
secularism is this philosophy that came
out of the Enlightenment out of the 18th
and 19th century in Europe and it was
imposed on the entire Globe by force
through colonialism through Imperial
Wars and the idea of liberal secularism
is that we morality should not be based
on these old books like the Quran and
the Bible we have to use reason and
science to maximize individual happiness
individual freedom and equality and this
is the best system of life it's an
atheistic system of life we need to have
separation of church and state Etc this
is the dominant I don't want to say
religion but it's a dominant ideology in
the world today and it's imposed through
you know the U.N security Council
International rights law Etc but it's
coming from a very specific philosophy
that is anti-religion it's anti-islam
it's anti-christianity anti-traditional
Christianity I criticize this system and
Muslims who criticize this system are
put on watch lists are TR we're banned
from traveling some of us are drone
striked some of us are detained some of
us face all kinds of canceling D
platforming our livelihoods are
threatened I get death threats all the
time almost every day I'm getting a
death threat because of my opposition to
this hegemony liberal secularism there
is no quote-unquote freedom of religion
because if you oppose this hegemony if
you oppose this system you will be put
to death and I know you've had some very
distinguished guests like Glenn
Greenwald Whitney Webb and they talk
about this system Alex Jones they talk
about this system they might not put in
the same exact way that I'm putting it
but it is a this authoritarian
centralized Theocratic not Theocratic
technological system and yes plenty of
people are getting killed what was the
Iraq War about what was the Afghanistan
war about how many millions of Muslims
were killed because of those invasions
what were those invasions Justified on
the basis of it wasn't on the basis of
the Bible I wouldn't put that on
Christians I would put it on spreading
Freedom spreading democracy spreading
liberal values and quote-unquote women's
rights that's what millions of Muslims
in the past 20 years have been killed
for slaughtered genocided because of
this ideology so yes Muslims are under
threat Muslims are on Far More on threat
than you know the few Christians here
and there that might leave Islam to
become Christian
go for it uh
well in the first place when it comes to
secular liberalism Daniel and I are
completely in agreement we're both
against it we both see that it's evil
and uh in that sense you know you were
talking about working together finding
common ground that is the common ground
that we have uh the idea of the
invasions of Iraq and Afghanistan were
completely wrong based on false premises
false assumptions uh based on the idea
that they could bring democracy to the
Islamic world it was never going to
happen I was warning about it before it
started but uh was not heated but the
fact is that and also uh when it comes
to death threats we could probably have
a contest and see but I get them many
many at many many daily mostly from
Muslims but not always and the left is
increasingly unhinged and out of control
but if Daniel is positing that Islam is
somehow the alternative then I would
wonder how is it that all the Muslim
politicians in the United States
including Sharia obvious publicly Sharia
adherent one like ilhan Omar and Rashida
tleb as well Keith Ellison uh the Andre
Carson the publicly Muslim uh Quran
adherent politicians and yet they're all
very far on the left and they're aiding
this secular liberal monster that Daniel
so rightly opposes and so it's hard to
see how Islam can be the remedy when you
don't even have a single politician
of the Islamic faith who is standing
against all that brother Rasheed what's
your what's your biggest criticism of
because you were a Muslim before and you
converted what was your biggest
reasoning for doing so
but my biggest reason and I I want to
comment on a point that I forgot to come
last time uh our brother he said the
five percent of Islam we are focusing on
right if you have this glass of water
and you have 95 for it is water but five
percent is poison it's going to kill you
so this is this is exactly what we have
with Islam yes you can talk about God
you talk about worshiping but how about
violence against people like me how
about violence against Christians and
Jews you are you are ordered to wage war
against them that's what happened to my
ancestors in Morocco berbers they were
Christians they were executed they were
enslaved that's what happened to people
in Egypt in Iraq in Syria and even in
Europe how about that how about
um uh people who uh for example against
women
Islam against women and women should
note that they endorsed the death
penalty for apostasy right here yeah
and and against women women should be
beaten if they disobey their their their
uh husbands my mom was beaten my Imam
Dad when I asked him why he said it's in
the Quran you cannot object to that they
cannot object to it it's in the Quran it
should be applied it's a permission for
men to beat his wife it's in the Quran
it's the word of Allah himself again
when I studied the life of Muhammad in
10 years he waged 83 Wars in 10 years 27
Wars and 56 raids in 10 years and you
are going to teach me that Islam is
peaceful no it's not peaceful are you
going to give a Nobel Prize for somebody
who waged 83 Wars no you win that and
and another thing Muhammad is not a rule
model Jesus is Muhammad he had many
wives 11 of them one of them she was
nine years old he was 53 I am 50. I
cannot marry a girl that has nine years
old you cannot that's abuse and Muhammad
did that
let me let me finish this he took he
raided a Jewish tribe he killed the
whole family of a newly bride called
Sophia
and
he took her as a wife the same time he
was returning to Medina would you put
that as a role model for me today in the
21st century he had another wife called
Rihanna my daughter her name is Rihanna
I named her specifically for that
he took a Jewish wife Rihanna and he he
did sex with her not with her will he
did against their Wills all these ladies
are you going to put him as a role model
you cannot compare Jesus with Muhammad
Jesus never killed a person he never
killed an apostate he never waged a war
so he was a role model for me and that's
why I loved Muhammad and I wanted to
follow Jesus they are going to keep
trying bring the Old Testament name one
person that Jesus killed because he was
an apostate Judas he he gave him to the
Jews and he never ordered his disciple
his disciples to kill him I have people
who just criticized Muhammad once
and he ordered his disciples to go and
kill him even lying his name is Ashraf
he's a Jewish guy they killed him they
lied to him they took him and they
killed him he he he even encouraged a
guy who was blind he killed his wife he
had two kids and he killed her he came
to the prayer and he said he said uh
Muhammad praised the guy for killing his
own wife just because she criticized
Muhammad so they these are the rules
that they want to apply today if we
criticize Muhammad we should be killed
like what happened with Charlie ibdu do
you think those people did just killed
the the people who drawed the caricature
for Muhammad just because of uh like
that no because it's written in in in
Islam that they should kill people who
criticized Muhammad so Islam is a big
problem even the five percent can kill
whole Humanity
can I have a response
um I want to comment on what he said and
also Roberts Robert's remark about us
endorsing the punishment for apostasy
yes we do why because our claim is that
we are actually faithful to our
scriptures you guys are not you want to
avoid the Old Testament and I want to
give you an analogy uh Patrick because
you're a business guy you have many
businesses okay and you have policies
that you have to put in place based on
social interaction in the workplace and
all that kind of stuff now you may make
amendments to those policies based on
new data new information how things are
actually going based on uh those things
that you put in place now when you do
right and and this is the analogy
between the Old Testament and the New
Testament are you willing to say that
well yeah uh thinking to myself yeah Pat
yeah you were wrong actually when you
said it was okay to do such and such
that was actually wrong and you then put
in the correct one with the Bible the
problem that you have is the same one
that you want to talk about the loving
Jesus Christ himself which we also adore
and respect as a prophet is the same one
that you believe is God and revealed the
Old Testament and you can't get out of
that so when your God Jesus revealed at
that specific time as I just read the
passage and I can read you plenty more
where he says to kill babies in war is
it okay to Target infants in war and
kill babies is that inherently immoral
the problem that you have is if you go
on and this is why the argument is so
important it's not a two-quote just as a
fallacious argument it's checking for
your consistency as a Christian whether
or or not you're actually faithful to
your own text and tradition and the
reality is you're not why you have two
options if you condemn it as inherently
immoral then the whole Bible's gone
because if you believe that those Bibles
were that those verses in the Bible were
revealed by God then you're saying that
God is immoral and on the other hand if
you say that it's not inherently immoral
but God changed the law at this time
then most of your arguments lose the
force that they have against Islam
because you can no longer argue that it
is inherently immoral to punish an
apostate by death and all of the other
things that you want to tack on this is
why it's so important it's not a
fallacious argument and the reality is
we want to stick to our texts and our
tradition and for the most part we would
argue that the Christians have abandoned
them in favor of secular liberal moral
ideologies let me have let me have
Daniel respond and then I'll come to you
go for it yeah so there are a lot of
things that we need to respond to
because he's just listing every
grievance that he has against Islam we
have to take it step by step but just on
this point of violence you know I think
Jake makes really The crucial point it's
that Jesus according to the Christian
belief Jesus is the god of the Old
Testament and he's the one who's
commanding Moses for example to uh
ethnically cleanse the Canaanites or the
amalekites or all of these other tribes
and to conduct conquests and War to take
girls as slaves to take virgins as
slaves this is in the Old Testament sure
so you have to deal Christians have to
deal with that moral problem a lot of
Christians Unfortunately they just throw
the Bible under the bus and you know how
is that justified but it's not just the
Old Testament it's also the New
Testament the New Testament also has
endorses slavery the New Testament also
has the Book of Revelation where Jesus
is going to come which by the way
Muslims also believe that Jesus is the
Messiah he is the born of the Virgin
Mary and he's going to come as the
Messiah to establish God's Kingdom on
Earth Muslims also accept and believe
that and we're anticipating that but
he's going to be very violent it's going
to be a very violent Affair and that's
in the Muslim tradition and the Hadith
and it's also in the Book of Revelation
so Jesus is also very violent and then
finally you have canon law you have the
church tradition so if Robert wants to
denounce canon law because when you have
canon law it has slavery it has a
marriage age of 12 years old in canon
law it has punishments for blasphemy it
has even
um you know striking the wife the
disobedient wife that's found in canon
law from gration so I believe that
Robert is an Orthodox Christian if he
wants to denounce canon law and denounce
his own tradition he can denounce that
he can denounce Jesus himself he can
denounce the Old Testament he can
denounce the Bible the New Testament
that's fine that's fine he says that oh
well our religion adapts our religion
changes but that's actually the problem
Patrick you know when we're talking
about wokism when we're talking about
about like if you can say that oh well
you know that's the Old Testament is for
those times it's not applicable now
right that's that's the argument the
violence the killing the killing of
blasphemers that's for old times we've
changed but Muslims are not willing to
change I say yeah Muslims are willing to
stand by Revelation the problem with a
lot of Christians not all Christians a
lot of Christians Jews Hindus they all
have these practices in their books
Buddhists they all have these practices
and they're pressured to change and
update and so why if you can get rid of
the conquest and the violence and the
punishment for apostasy why not just get
rid of the prohibition of like
cross-dressing the prohibition of
homosexuality the prohibition of drag
queens why prohibit any of that like
maybe times are different maybe we need
to adopt drag queen Story Hour in our
church maybe we need to adopt you know
all of these woke practices why not and
Robert here's what I would say you're
making a very good argument and I can
totally feel where you're coming from as
well obviously just so everybody knows
have we ever had a conversation together
prior to this debate I just want
everybody that's watching have you and I
ever spoken we just met a few minutes
have you and I ever smoked have you and
I no I did that intentionally I did that
intentionally because I wanted to be the
first interaction we have where it's not
like well you know this topic do you
want this do you want that and nobody
was given additional topics or what you
just kind of came in we're going to talk
we can have this discussion again I
respect you guys for doing this I think
the part I agree with Daniel and it
could be a it could be a leak it could
be a flaw or it could be a a strength as
well as the following
the what I'm noticing between the two
faith is one seems to be more intolerant
more intolerant and the other one's more
tolerant let me unpack that from my
perspective for the longest time since I
became a since I started praying
September of 1997 I prayed for four
things courage wisdom tolerance
understanding the last six months I've
been having a hard time praying for the
third thing which is tolerance and the
reason for it is because I think
Christians are becoming way too tolerant
now the standards could be extreme
somebody could be watching the same guys
what are you talking about you mean to
tell me you're okay to hit your wife and
do this and do that and apostasy and all
this stuff that's ridiculous for you to
think that and you may say well look
we're at least staying committed to our
faith they're not they're picking and
choosing what they like and they're not
that could be the argument all I'm
saying is that's their argument what
they're saying yeah but then the other
side is when you're saying what you're
saying you know stats came out right now
as well about uh peer research on
statistics on Muslims view on lgbtq
you're now going to go through this as
well with your faith with your religion
peer research says that 52 percent of
American Muslims believe homosexuality
should be accepted by Society this is
according to peer research among Muslim
American Millennials that jump to 60
percent this was done in 2017 so it's
six years old which I would assume it's
even higher today than what it was then
the survey also revealed that Muslim
women are much more accepting of LGB
people than their male counterparts
they're at 63 percent men are at 42
percent just so you know the difference
between women and men about 21
difference and a vast majority of
religious lgbtq Americans are Christians
split to a fairly amongst Catholics 25
percent
Protestants 28 percent and Christian
denomination 24.5 only about two and a
half percent uh of Jews uh uh are Fort
and two percent of Muslims okay so he
makes the point that you know you are
more tolerant of a religion of when I
say you you're not representing
everybody in the Christian you could be
your own kind of a Christian there's
different you know sex and a Christian
but I from an outsider watching in and
trying to be as Fair as possible I see
we're not being tolerant you're not
going to say anything about our Prophet
you're not going to say anything about
our religion we're going to defend this
these are our values we're going to
protect them we're going to fight for
this is important to us this is our
livelihood this is what we stand for and
Christians are like ah it's okay don't
worry about it it's okay don't worry
about it it's okay don't worry about it
and then it's bringing out more flaws
and arguments in the Christian religion
and I'm saying this as a Christian
myself what's your rebuttal to that well
what you're talking about in a large
part is a retreat from and a rejection
of Christianity not actual Christianity
Christianity stands for certain values
stands for certain principles and when
the West Was Christian then you didn't
see all this craziness that you see in
the society today it's when the West
starts to discard Christianity that all
these things come in like Chesterton
said when people stop believing in God
it's not that they believe in nothing
they believe in anything and we're
seeing that Illustrated every day now
with increasingly insane public
discourse coming from the left and
especially a social discourse but this
is not Christianity now to be sure
you're absolutely right there are a lot
of leftists and liberal Christians who
have essentially discarded Christianity
yeah and under the guise of Christianity
that's kind of like Invasion of the Body
Snatchers Christianity you remember that
movie people would appear and they
looked just the same but the space
aliens had taken their personalities and
replaced them and that's what we have
with a great deal of Christianity today
unfortunately it's been infected by
exactly this kind of liberalism and so a
lot of people turn away thinking that's
Christianity when actually these people
are not Christian in anything except the
name but there's a great deal more that
Daniel mentioned am I going to get a
chance you can you can respond right now
okay the uh thing the problem that you
guys have is that you're reading the
Bible as if it were the Quran in the
Quran it's dictated every Allah dictated
every word and it's applicable for all
time it's all flattened out and on the
same level the Bible is simply not like
that in the first place you have the
very simple notation of the gospels The
Gospel according to Matthew Mark Luke
and John now in the Christian faith
Matthew Mark Luke and John were inspired
but that doesn't mean that God was
dictating to them and that it was beyond
their human understanding like when
Saint Paul in one of his letters and he
says I'm glad I didn't come to baptize
any of you well actually I did baptize a
couple people and I forget who else but
I still didn't come to baptize it's not
that God is forgetting who he baptized
and who he didn't but Paul is working
from his human understand standing and
yet he is speaking the truth the Eternal
truths that God wants him to communicate
a lot of the Bible is the record of the
evolving understanding of the people of
God about precisely a lot of these
issues that you're talking about and so
you can't go back and flatten it out as
if it were the Quran and say Jesus is
here telling people to kill people and
therefore you have to approve of it but
Jesus that's not how the Bible Works
what you have is an understanding that
the people had at that time that's
expressed in that way and then later
because of the teachings that Jesus
gives in the New Testament primarily of
the Dignity of the universal Dignity of
the human person and of various other
aspects of the understanding of humanity
that's why slavery is abolished and
slavery was only abolished in Christian
contexts primarily in in the UK and the
United States to start with and then it
followed around the world because people
understood even though slavery is in the
Bible and in the New Testament yes at
the same time also there's the idea that
all people are made in the image of God
and have that dignity so there's not the
dichotomy like in the Quran Muhammad is
the Apostle of Allah those who follow
him and merciful to one another ruthless
to the unbelievers of chapter 48 verse
29 so in the it was Christian clerics in
the UK and the United States who led the
fight to abolish slavery based on the
deeper Christian principles regarding
the Dignity of the human person yeah so
why can't you evolve why can't
Christians evolve to accept transgenders
and drag queen story are why can't
things evolve even more actually because
of the same the principles yeah it's a
good question I'm trying to answer it
there's a there is it's because of the
same principles the idea of transgender
yeah human dignity and that means both
physically and spiritually and so you
take the transgender business that's a
total rejection of trust in God and the
idea that God knows what he's doing when
he creates somebody male and female
that's the first thing the Bible tells
us about God that he created the heavens
and the Earth
and well sure
human dignity male and female something
created we are and being tolerant for
who we are yes that's what they what
they call that's why we're calculated we
have heresies a very clear-cut principle
we have heresies and Christianity that's
like you do in Islam No No but I want to
understand what is the principle I've
been telling you that you have human
dignity you're talking over me but I'm
trying to explain it to you because
you're not is that a question no I
actually am answering the question but
you keep interrupting me and making it
impossible for me to make that give me
the principles so if you had the basic
courtesy to be quiet for a second then I
will return it to you when you respond
sure but the idea that when when it says
male and female he created them that's
not just an incidental point but that is
fundamental to the human identity and to
the nature of the person that has that
dignity as being made in the image of
God and consequently to say oh no God
made a big mistake and I'm really a
woman that is a fundamental rejection of
any kind of Christian principle
let me ask a question here afford
appointment I want to transition off
this topic to the next topic by the way
you know how the Constitution we've had
27 amendments in the last however many
years we've been around right based on
what he just said my interpretation what
he said is the religion of Christianity
has made many amendments over the years
okay somebody could interpret as the New
Testament as a form of an amendment you
can push back I'm just giving the
audience trying to see what the average
audience may be thinking about they may
say no the quranas the Quran is the
Quran we follow what was taught back in
the days and we're sticking to it and
there's no amendments what's your
rebuttal today
yes you understand what I'm saying I
understand the question first of all
they are talking about amendments they
have something in Islam called
abrogation it's like an amendment God
says something and then he changes it
for example he asked the question was it
moral to kill the apostate I can ask him
the same question
like you marry for like it was practiced
in Iran a lot uh you're just not
inherently immoral it's not an
inherently anymore why we can answer it
why why it was stopped why Muhammad
stopped it if it was immoral the
difference I'm just giving you an
example let's ask the question no no
I'll let you answer I'll let you answer
in in Christianity Jesus came he stopped
so many things in the Old Testament
that's our principle he stopped for
example sacrifices we don't sacrifice
animals he stopped the adulterers to be
stoned he stopped so many things like
Truth for tooth he stopped that so Jesus
stopped so many things in the Old
Testament you don't accept that that's
that's that's your choice for example
why his disciples never killed an
apostate why his disciples never have
political power as soon as Christians
gained political power in the Roman
Empire they started doing these things
they didn't have the jurisdiction to do
so they didn't care the minority they
weren't in power and as soon as
Christians gained power within the Roman
Empire they applied the Old Testament
laws the New Testament it's not true
notified in the canon law
Jesus never waged a war he never ordered
one there were others they were there
were other Jews uh who did who did Kill
uh Romans and who did kill people Zealot
the the the the people called rayorun so
um Jesus never ordered that his
disciples got killed not waged war they
got killed they never killed a person
slavery uh Paul the Apostle Paul he said
in Jesus there is no slave or free and
that's why the the abolitionists they
started in the west I have a question
for you you are benefiting from Human
Rights and freedom of religion in the
U.S and you are trying to get us back to
Sharia for example you converted from
Christianity to Islam and you want to
bring a law that kills the apostle do
you want to be killed for converting
from Christianity to Islam do you want
that do you believe it's correct do you
want it you believe it's correct answer
the question
the principle is the Golden Rule do not
do to people what do you don't want them
to do to you so you talk for a long time
can I respond please okay
both of you keep running from the Old
Testament and the argument that I've
given Jesus stopped it right Jesus stop
we let you we let you speak for a while
sir please let me talk okay
is Jesus God well yes the answer is yes
you do believe that did God reveal at
least parts of the Old Testament well of
course you believe that now Robert
wanted to make a distinction he brought
up an example about Paul trying to
remember how many people he baptized is
baptized but in the Old Testament when
it says that God is speaking and that
God commanded X was that just somebody
making it up or misremembering no the
Bible says it's God so listen to this
passage first Samuel 15 1-3 and Samuel
said to Saul the Lord sent me to anoint
you King over his people Israel not oh
I'm just talking at it you know my
backside now therefore listen to the
words of the Lord who are they the words
of the lord they're not the words of
Samuel or your neighbor John or whoever
else thus says the Lord of hosts I have
noted what amalek did to Israel in
opposing them on the way way when they
came out of Egypt now go and strike
amalek and devote to destruction all
that they have do not spare them but
kill both man and woman child and infant
ox and sheep camel and Donkey so do not
tell me sir that God Jesus did not order
the killing of innocent people he not
only did he do that he ordered the
killing of babies none of which you will
ever find anywhere in the Quran or
Sunnah so if you have a problem let me
finish her let me finish sir if you have
a problem with God ordering debt for
apostasy and all these other things that
you're bringing up Robert when you bring
up the issue of Paul well he's trying to
remember how many people he baptized is
that analogous to this text where a
prophet Samuel is explicitly saying that
these are the words of the Lord with
Samuel lying did God actually say this
and if so is killing babies inherently
immoral when at War yeah killing babies
is bad Jake yes is it inherently immoral
yeah so why did your God order Jesus
Jesus
why did your the problem you have once
again
if you let me answer the problem that
you have once again is that you're
reading the Bible as if it were the
Quran and see these things actually
trouble Jews and Christians there's no
no uh uh reason to cover up that fact
that these passages have caused
difficulty why is it for Jews and
Christians throughout history and some
people would say actually these things
never happened at all that they were uh
they were they were fables designed to
teach do you believe that they were
fables designed to teach that you are to
be completely pure and reject sin and
that all that business about killing
this one and that one is about rejecting
various now the whole point of what I'm
saying here if you would stop
interrupting for a minute I did not
interrupt you the whole point of what
I'm saying here is that these passages
precisely in the fact that they have
caused trouble for Jews and Christians
and have led to differing
interpretations of them demonstrate that
the Jews and Christians both have a
evolving understanding that comes from
later Revelations and that comes from
their own in under interpretation of the
revelations that they received such that
they can say unequivocally that yes
killing innocent people is wrong whereas
you have Muhammad and they ask him you
know you're you're throwing rocks you're
catapulting stones into the infidels
City on you might they got women and
children in there and he says oh they're
among them in other words you know it
doesn't really matter if you kill women
and children because they're all
infidels and you don't have any kind of
critical
stepping back and saying maybe that is
not to be that's the one I'm talking
about can you read this time he said
there's no permissibility
will you stop interrupting me I did not
interrupt you permissibility of killing
women and children in night raids so
long as it is not done deliberately it
is reported on the authority of Saab IBM
jathama that the prophet of Allah when
asked about the women and children of
the polytheists being killed during the
night raid said they are from them and
this is
and that once I make the point yeah
that that is
giving permission and that's actually
was invoked by zarkawi the al-Qaeda
leader in Iraq when he was explaining
why women and children were killed by
the Jihad bombings and he was actually
justifying it among Muslims and he
invoked that passage okay so so the
difference is if you actually read the
next Hadith afterwards it clarifies it
sir and yes if you're talking about
bombardment or collateral damage in
which an infant or child or a woman may
be harmed
inadvertently and unintentionally then
yes that can happen it's not a good
thing that we enjoy in war but if it
happens so be it the difference is that
in this text it specifically commanding
from God and what you said before well
some Christians say well it's not
actually historical maybe it didn't
happen well I don't care about other
Christians with all due respect for this
conversation we're talking to the two of
you and the two Muslims and we are
representing our positions so we want to
know from you do you believe that first
Samuel 15 1-3 was revealed by God and
that God himself ordered directly
intentionally for the killing of babies
and infants let me answer that let me
answer that you are judging a war that
happened 3 000 years ago just just wait
you are judging a war that happened
three thousand years ago by the
standards of today the difference
between the Old Testament and Islam We
Believe those applied for those
circumstances and stayed there they
should not be applied today Islam Jihad
should be applied in the time of
Muhammad today and forever so killing
the kids of politics Muhammad answered
Dr from them they are just polytheists
like them so it's okay to kill them and
let me tell you about killing kids how
you define a kid in the raid of Benny
joraida benicode a Jewish tribe Muhammad
came and he said check the hair of
puberty for every kid if you find one
here you can kill him because he's
considered an adolescent so they killed
600 people on that day you want to tell
me that doesn't exist in Islam I know it
exists in Islam and I know if you got
Authority today you will do it here's
what I want to do I want to have Daniel
give a response and then I'm going to go
to the next topic go for Daniel okay so
those that was a tribe that betrayed the
Muslims in war so that was an act of
treason every legal system in history
every religion when you do an act of
treason and War what's the punishment
for that capital punishment and that was
what was applied the punishment fit the
crime uh the point that Jake made is
that the prophet peace be upon him uh
explicitly forbade the intentional
killing of women and children in the
Hadith that you didn't mention so this
is dishonest you read one Hadith from
the book of jihad in sahih Muslim but
you don't read the other Hadith so that
is dishonest on your part sir
um and then let's let's bring it back
you know to the overall picture because
for your viewers and many of them might
not be Muslim or Christian they think
like both of you guys are crazy both of
you your religious sound ridiculous so I
want to defend not only traditional
Islam but also traditional Christianity
you know I want to defend I think that's
what bridging uh Building Bridges is
really about defending traditional
religion where every religion has
Conquest it has violence it has rules of
war and guess what we live in a world of
real politique every nation is engaging
in War of Conquest expanding its
influence and using violence as a means
the U.S is the biggest perpetrator of
that the Russian now is doing that in
Ukraine endorsed by the Orthodox Church
by the way you have China who is also
expanding its influence so every society
every culture every traditional religion
says yes use means and violence if
necessary to expand your influence and
to conquer and to Conquest and to impose
pose impose what your values that is
something universe as Muslims we're
proud of that sorry as Muslims we're
proud of that we're proud of our
religion and we're not going to uh
reform it and modify it it's only modern
Christians actually and these other
religions that are reforming their
traditional beliefs in deference to what
in deference to this hegemony that I'm
talking about the liberal secular powers
and saying no no our religion is just
about peace our religion is just about
like no violence no nothing okay you
have to throw all your traditional texts
under the bus Muslims are not willing to
do that and and that's and that argument
has been made clearly and the audience
has to decide which to them seems more
of a uh Faith which leads me to the next
question of Faith where you would want
to raise your family in a country based
on those values so in America when you
look at the statistics you'll see 20 000
Christians have converted to Muslim
right of which uh 75 are women the
number we'll see 3 4 orders of women and
a quarter of men okay the question I
would have is I lived in Iran for 10
years I don't know if you guys have
lived in a Muslim Nation before did you
live did you do you lived obviously you
lived in Morocco have you lived in a
Muslim uh you're here so I lived in Iran
10 years as a Christian family and we
would go to church and I went to
Christian school and then we escaped and
went to Germany lived at a refugee camp
with a lot of different sex from
different parts of the world who were
escaping they were either escaping
communism uh or they were escaping not
feeling safe persecution for their
religion what they believed in they
didn't have the freedom they left
why why is it this is a question that's
been brought up when I'm crowdsourcing
what questions you want us to ask the
guests that are here today
if it's purely statistical why are more
Muslims moving to Christian nations and
not Christian nations moving to Muslim
nations why do you think that is it's
economics pure economics if you look at
Christians that move to Saudi and the
gulf there's a huge influx of Christians
from the Philippines from Africa from
Eastern Europe that flock to the gulf
countries Muslim countries why because
of GDP because of the economy the influx
of people of all religions and cultures
to the U.S to Australia to Europe it's
purely because of Economic Opportunity
not because of there's some kind of
better way of life the way of life in
the U.S and I can talk to you because
you live 10 years in Iran the culture of
traditional societies especially Muslim
societies is much more conducive to
family it's more of a family
community-based life as opposed to
individualistic you know Rat Race
everyone is out for himself type of
lifestyle that you live in the west and
that's because of the hegemony that
we're talking about because of liberal
secularism because of this Pursuit of
Happiness at the expense of all else
when you have a religion that values
family marriage look at the divorce
rates look at how you know I have five
sons of my own I'm very worried about
will they even be able to find a wife
who will be faithful to them and who
will want to have children my
grandchildren who will be faithful look
at the divorce rates look at the
infidelity rates look at all of the
social problems that are infecting
Western societies why is that I'd argue
it's on the basis of leaving traditional
Christianity leaving traditional Islam
reforming these religions that's the
problem look at someone like Reza Aslan
you interviewed I had one yeah and you
had a brilliant comment you said that
Reza when you're talking I feel like
you're an atheist you're arguing I don't
think that you're actually a Muslim like
you're not talking like you're a Muslim
you're talking like this Progressive
liberal atheist type person and that's
what's happening to everyone because of
these political forces and we have to
resist that we have to resist those
kinds of influences in order to preserve
marriage preserve family preserve
community that exists in the Muslim
world but it's being eroded so so why
are you still here why are you in
America why don't you go to a Muslim
Nation I would like to do that but the
thing is that the West has declared war
on every traditional Society every
Trader if you don't Implement western
style liberal uh human rights quote
unquote like you Don't Legalize
homosexuality You Don't Legalize
transgender You Don't Legalize feminism
all these things are destroying marriage
and family we're going to bomb you we're
going to sanction you we're going to
starve your people it's not safe for
Muslims to be in Muslim countries it's
not safe for traditional Christians in
traditional Christians quoting the Bible
within Europe are being put in in prison
for quoting the Bible they'll literally
quote a verse from Leviticus or they'll
talk about Sodom and Gomorrah they're
put in prison this is a war on all
traditional religions and there's not a
safe place for a traditional religious
person in the world today because of
this dominant Global power so your
argument is is economy capitalism you
know a capitalistic Society so then the
question would be why don't Muslim
regions accept the principles of a
capitalistic free Society to be able to
attract other Christians you know
because when you hear some stories but I
I got that uh brother Rashid do you ever
respond to him on on this question
specifically the question I'm asking why
do Christian nations attract Muslims but
Muslim nations not attract Christians
you say the economy is the first reason
but but um other reasons exist too I
have seen so many Saudi girls live in
Saudi Arabia going to Canada in the US
and the UK they're asking for Asylum
because they don't have the same rights
and they are forced to stay as a second
class status women is not treated well
in in Muslim countries I have seen
people who are leaving Morocco and other
places because they don't have freedom
of speech and and if you say anything
against Islam in Egypt or or Morocco or
for me for example why I left Morocco I
love Morocco I would love I would love
to live among my family but I left not
because of the economy I was doing well
but because I don't have freedom of
religion and and and there are many
countries are like that if you open the
borders in Europe and the U.S you have
almost probably I I can't guess but like
probably 90 percent of Muslims will will
go to the West not just because of money
it's because of other reasons they are
oppressed there and our brothers they
have the their solution to what will
live is not what I am he here of course
we have a problem in the west but the
solution they are given is worse than
what we have today for example lgbtq
whatever they will they will kill them
if we bring guess let's say let them
govern with Islam today they will throw
them from a higher building that's their
punishment I'm not with that I'm not
either this the two extremes either this
or that Islam is not going to give a
solution why we have human rights in the
west why every everything we are
enjoying today came from the West for
example women rights came from the West
uh
uh polishing slavery came from the West
freedom of speech freedom of religion
came from the West
uh you name it just give me anything
democracies came from the West
so they want us to live under an
authoritarian
a system and you cannot even question it
and if you say anything against it you
will be condemned to death for example
if I say Islam is not the right way to
God I cannot say that in a Muslim
country I will be punished for that so
we are enjoying freedom of speech
freedom of religion democracy we can say
our opinion we can have a podcast like
that without a problem guess what in
Morocco when I became a Christian we met
as Christians in closed doors we
couldn't sing we couldn't baptize people
we couldn't name our kids Christian
names you cannot name Him Luke or Mark
or anything you have to name him
Muhammad and um you can't name them
Christian names this is not correct it's
true I lived it
yeah you don't talk about other
Christians questions can name their
children okay
country okay let me finish Patrick is
that against the law let me finish I am
a convert from Islam to Christianity
like me
they will we were gathering we were
afraid of police and we got arrested
many times we got into a game let me get
this straight so I want to understand
what both of you are saying so for us I
was born in a Muslim country my name is
Patrick my sister's name is Paulette
you're saying if a Muslim converts to
Christian you can't just name your kids
anything you have to name them those
specific names yes and you're okay with
that you think that's normal I said
something even you know more than that I
said that the punishment is death
penalty so forget it that's what we
talked about at the beginning so so for
you it's not even your level for that is
for somebody to go but why is that
that's not the treatment of all
Christians
why do you believe that why do you
believe if a Muslim becomes a Christian
is the death penalty well this is what I
want to explain is that
um first of all this is found in every
religion it's found in every culture the
idea that you have to have punishments
for defection meaning that if you
abandon the group you are threatening
the group and that's why everybody
business every University every society
has Community guidelines for example if
you violate the community guidelines
it's not called blasphemy it's called a
violation of community guidelines you're
expelled from that Community you face
consequences but it goes beyond that
because you have uh restrictions on your
speech right I can't we can't look at
you know this YouTube channel I can't
say certain things on this live stream
otherwise the video will be banned your
channel will get in trouble and then you
can be prosecuted you can face all kinds
of consequences again go back to your
Glenn Greenwald interview your interview
with Whitney Webb look at the power
structures that restrict speech they
restrict thought it why in order to
preserve the power structure every
religion has this traditional
Christianity that's why Heretics were
punished that's why apostates were
punished
so when you when you say to me you know
I've interviewed almost any of the major
living mobster I've had them on the
podcast before I don't know if that's
your stuff that you would watch but I've
been over a lot of them Michael Francis
there's a lot of these guys okay so I
can see you with your last name yes so
so so so so when I interview these guys
one of the things that they have and
Sammy is a very much of a he says look
I'm a mafia so I'm a true mafios was
what I am till today he's in his late
70s he still says that right if you step
away from the life like it's a you could
get killed if you step away from the
life right okay you chose this life you
celebrated when you become a maid man
now you want to leave you got the
benefits of being a maid man now you
want to leave we're going to take your
life if based on the principles that
they followed but that's the mafia youth
for somebody that may say well then
Islam is you know is Islam following
some of the mafia philosophies that if
you choose to leave you deserve to get
to lose your life don't you think that's
a bit extreme I would say the problem
with the mafia is criminal activity it's
not with this principle this is a good
principle that's why they're able to be
so organized that's why they're able to
be so successful that's the argument and
and you have Nations that are run in the
same way you have to preserve the nation
by punishing defection because it
threatens the unity of the group it
threatens the way of life so that's the
law I totally understand it all I'm
saying is that's that's tough because
okay so let me get to more the business
side the next item let me just add a
little bit to it go for it I will be
killed my kids will be taken and my wife
will be taken at the
jet to the list in in an Islamic system
let me let me let me continue with this
let me continue with this a little bit
because this is getting interesting to
me
so if if in Insurance there's two ways
to build or real estate there's two ways
guys build their real estate in their
insurance companies let me explain this
and you'll see where I'm going with this
question one is there's guys that steal
from other people okay and they'll say
oh you train those guys I'll take your
agents you train those guys I'll take
your agents you're getting sixty percent
I'll give you 80 if you come to my
company so their entire business model
is to take from others right and then
they're always capped because somebody
else is not going to come and say he
gave you 80 I'll give you a hundred and
so now they go to a different guy and
then the other guy will say that he gave
you 100 I'll give you 110 then they'll
realize there's only 130. so how much
more is left to do I'll give you 115 if
you come to me five more okay I'll come
to you and then eventually you're stuck
you're not gonna go anywhere right okay
so they're not these agencies are not
baptism agencies they're converting
agencies I'll convert you to me by me
giving you a better life or better
heaven or better you know dream that I'm
selling to you right
for me the way I see it is on and then
the other side is guys that recruit
people from other Industries and they
make them Realtors so I'm working at
Sears you should consider getting a real
estate license I convert you you're a
nurse you should think about being a
realtor I become a realtor so you
understand the two examples I'm giving
I'm recruiting other Realtors and
converting somebody into being a realtor
hence religion Muslim I'm targeting
Christians to convert them no I'm
converting people that are you know
becoming Muslims or just we're having
more kids and that's how we're going to
grow religion okay so the criticism and
fear that a lot of Christians will say
non-muslims will say is if we go the way
we do right now one day Muslims are
going to run the world do you not fear
that and you'll hear that okay and by
the way it's a fair argument because
right now the number is give or take the
Muslim population worldwide I think is
around uh 1.7 billion and it's expected
by 2060 to grow by 73 74 to 3.1 billion
today they're 24.1 percent of the world
population by 2060 you'll be 31.1
percent these are some real numbers that
they're increasing and Christians will
say well do you not are you not worried
about that are you not worried about
that are you not worried about that okay
so then my argument becomes because I'm
a data guy Muslim women have 2.9 kids
per woman
Christians are around 2.5 2.6
non-muslims are 2.2 and you know the
replacement game you need to have 2.1
yeah so 2.1 is a replacement game 2.2 is
non-muslims Christians are 2.6 and then
you have Muslims leading the way 2.9 by
the way in the 90s you were at 4.34.5 in
1990 1995 30 years ago you were at 2 4.5
4.3 so where am I going with this
so where I'm going with this is if this
goes the way it does
and they do what they do it is very
natural that the Senate that Congress
that house that Governors are going to
be ran by Muslims right now you have
three that are there you mentioned the
names earlier they used to be one in the
past that's four but we had 82 in the
midterm election who are Muslims that
got elected to city state different kind
of jobs that they had record-breaking
ever right
so if I don't look at it from the faith
standpoint
if I don't look at it from the religion
standpoint if I don't look at it from
the argument of who's right who's wrong
Muhammad Jesus if I don't look at it
from there I would simply say their
strategy of conver their strategy of
growing is kicking Christian's tail so
then Christians can either sit there and
complain about it or they can do
something about it but Christians don't
want to have that many kids Christians
are not having four five six kids he has
five he said you have five Sons okay
he's got five Sons I don't know how many
of you have five Sons at the table I got
two and two girls five Sons is gonna be
the rest of us right if he's gonna keep
having these kids so what is your
solution as a Christian and I'm purely
talking business right now the business
of religion is what I'm talking right
now according to the business of
religion they're going to win and
there's nothing Christians can do about
it by the business you can sit and argue
to Faith all you want they're getting
their people and their kids baptized
because their job isn't recruiting
Christians to become Muslims they've
only converted twenty thousand that's
not a lot it's not a big number but
they're getting more kids and they're
raising their kids with the loyalty to
the parents and they're following that
faith and they're growing bigger and
we're not doing that what is what are
your thoughts to that well if you're
asking me what the solution is obviously
Christians have to recover a sense of
their faith and a sense of what's at
stake because what you're talking about
will happen if this continues is that
the United States will look like Egypt
or Saudi Arabia or Iran those were not
always the heart of the Islamic World
those were conquered and islamized and
the Christians were like Rasheed was
saying were put made second class made
subject to all kinds of humiliating and
discriminatory regulations and had to
pay a special tax that's specified in
the Quran chapter 9 verse 29 and they
ultimately most of them in those areas
and in North Africa other areas like
that they uh many of them thought you
know why am I suffering this and having
to live in this way all I have to do is
convert to Islam and I can live a decent
life and most of them did and so you
have areas that were 99 Christian and
now they're 99 Muslim and so people
don't realize they think they look at
Egypt and they say well that's the
Islamic World they don't realize that
these things are always in flux and that
exactly what happened there is beginning
to happen in the west and so I think
that if Christians were to come to
realize what's at stake which would be
extraordinarily difficult given the
amount of propaganda and falsehood that
spread about these issues in the
mainstream then they might begin to
realize that they need to take what's
the solution though what's the what's
the next steps what is the solution for
your standpoint they have to have larger
families certainly and have to meet the
the the dawa the proselytizing
initiatives and be able to answer all
the objections to show the the in main
aspects of Christians are not they're
United these guys are right exactly so
Christians are competing against each
other Muslims are more united no I I
disagree to that but we have Shia we
have Sunni they are fighting each other
killing each other fair enough yes and
and so they are not really United and if
you go to salafis they will make the
sophies are as much but would you agree
that sunnis and shias are United at
least in the values no not necessarily
because you know the cousin or you know
that's the History part where who got
the past time I'm talking purely values
and philosophies you know what Muslims
will claim we are 1.7 and when you ask
them details they will be ahmadis are
not Muslims Muslims and you will find
just the guy in his mask at the end
instead of 1.7 I live that when you
really scrutinize them you will find
just the guy in his mask they are the
ones actually Muhammad said his his
people will divide to 73 uh groups and
one of them only go to heaven so 72 of
them they're just like kofar they are
not really Muslims so let's go back to
that a replacement rate for example in
some countries like Iran is below it's
below 2.1 in Turkey it's below 2.1 in
others they are below that so there is
there is a huge drop for example in
Morocco I think it was like 6.9 and now
it's like 2.8 or 2.7 so next generation
will be below replacement rate so you
will suffer also from from uh you
believe that you believe their numbers
is going to go below the Christian yeah
I will believe they will drop because we
have so many challenges economy so many
other things and another thing they
don't count how many people are leaving
Islam we don't have statistics I have
statistics for example people who write
to me according just to my show from
Morocco from Algeria from Iran for
example so many people are leaving to
atheism to Christianity other to other
World Views in Egypt in Saudi Arabia
City don't count that I still counted as
a Muslim in the 1.7 yeah and many people
like me so if they give freedom and we
do real surveys we will have the number
less another thing what Islam is left
the West forced Muslims to abolish
slavery do not practice the Real Islam
like imputing hands and feeds and
crucifying they are now forcing them to
have one wife so Islam the version of
Islam and the Muslim world is not really
what they are preaching so what Muslims
do we have according to their standards
probably most of them are kefir and not
only that's because of the death penalty
for apostasy that this is unreported but
also there was a survey and people did
answer the anonymous survey recently in
Iran only 40 percent of the population
identified as Muslim now that's
extraordinary and it shows how inhumane
Sharia Islamic law is I don't remember
who ran it but it's easy to find we can
look it up can you look it up 1979 to
now we've had Islamic law in Iran and
now only Now 60 of Iranians have
rejected Islam that's because they've
lived it since 1979 and they realize how
much they don't like it
yeah I just want to comment because
they're talking a lot about the supposed
disunity amongst uh Muslims as if you
don't have that in Christianity right oh
yeah you do you do right so uh Rasheed I
know that Robert here is uh Eastern
Orthodoxy he used to be Catholic uh what
denomination or sect of Christianity do
you belong to because we are Converse in
Morocco we don't follow anything we just
follow I'm saying like do you go to a
specific church I meant went to many
Orthodox Protestant I don't care okay so
anyway my point is you have the three
main sex in Christianity the Protestants
the Catholics the Eastern Orthodox
historically they fought with each other
over very you know what from the outside
people would think well why are they
fighting over this I mean today the
Orthodox and Catholics are fighting over
uh doctrines like the filioque whether
or not the uh Holy Spirit proceeds for
it from the father and the son or the
father alone eternally and and and
they're completely divided on this and
you know call each other Heretics and
all kinds of stuff so to act as if right
there's this division among sunnis and
Shia when as I think Patrick rightly
pointed out we have much more in common
in terms of our actual values we differ
in terms of certain historical doctrines
but that's another story on the other
hand you have so many different sects
within Christianity so many different
denominations all of them disagree and
consider the each other to be Heretics
so for you to make that accusation and
critique of Islam I just don't think is
corrected the history of the Catholics
versus Protestants in Europe over five
years children the wake of the
Protestant Reformation so I mean that's
a
um that applies to Christianity more
than Islam but going back to Patrick's
Point is that you want to grow your
numbers and the grow the Christian
population I want to help Christians
grow because I think a world that has
more Christians is better than a world
that has more atheists but how can you
have more Christians when you don't
really believe in the Bible we have the
seeds of the destruction of Christianity
right in this podcast because when you
look at the way that Robert and Rasheed
describe the Bible they describe it as a
book of fables and it can continue to
evolve I didn't say that this is going
to this is going to cause apostasy this
is going to cause a decrease in faith
like why should I take Christianity
seriously when it just evolves and it
changes over time I can't connect my
practices and my beliefs as a Christian
today with the historical Jesus so why
am I going to maintain myself as a
Christian and then also the the whole
theology which we haven't discussed at
all today like the 95 monotheism is uh
80 to 90 percent of the world believes
in monotheism in one God and monotheism
is a central crucial the most important
part of Islam the belief in one one God
Without Partners he is not like anything
this is a very powerful belief that 80
to 90 percent of human beings profess in
this day and age and Islam represents
that in its Theology and emphasizes that
in its theology but if you have a
trinity or you have a theology that is
not really clear as Jesus God is there a
godhead is there this other system do we
go by the Catholics or do we go by the
Orthodox do we go by the Protestants you
don't have a consistent Theology sunnis
and shias they all agree on the on
monotheism God is one he is not like
anything they agree on the Quran yeah
there can be some theological
differences and nuances between
different schools but there's not the
same kind of disparity or variance
between Christian sects and this idea of
the Trinity which frankly no one can
understand like what does it mean to be
three in one
my brother is mentioning divisions
between Catholics and Protestants if I
go back there are divisions among the
the follower the Disciples of Muhammad
the sahaba themselves they killed each
other you know that the wife of Muhammad
went and killed the followers of Ali in
Moka ATL Gemma thousands died among the
first disciples this didn't happen
between Peter and John by the way and so
if you go to Islam from the beginning
they fought each other and they had
divisions from the beginning you know
that for example the fight over the
Quran was created or Eternal they fought
over that and actually one time they had
the whole caliphate going one way the
other time the prison they killed people
who believed that so you're trying just
to give a fake picture there are
divisions there are killings among
Muslims all through history from the
beginning from the start with didn't
happen within Christianity by the way
Peter and uh we didn't kill each other
didn't kill each other
okay oh wow were they fighting each
other
for example who killed when Peter and
James were they at or were they fighting
were they were they they were not
fighting okay fight is to take an Army
against another one Aisha took an army
and killed people you don't have an
argument
you lost your argument you're trying to
make make a false analogy here you lost
your argument this is not a neurology
you're not gonna you're not gonna win
over any Christians by making
constructing these straw man arguments
that completely misrepresents
but if I may and I want to hear your
your thoughts just a quick rebuttal here
my point earlier is I don't think
they're trying to convert
because because I think hear me out oh
sure they are I'm sure they are I'm sure
they are but I don't think that's where
they rely on the earlier point I made
their strategy on outgrowing Christians
is to internally raise kids from the
beginning rather than converting oh yeah
that's the way they're gonna be you know
able to do what they want to do so if
you want to respond go right well they
are they are obviously converting
Christians because Jake is here but uh
the fact is twenty thousand Islam is not
really that attractive a message and so
there are many people who are converts
most of the people like you're saying
the reason why it's growing is because
of polygamy and because the uh women
have many many more children than women
in the west do but in any case the uh
points that I was making are completely
misrepresenting and running with your
misunderstanding and claiming I said
things I never said the point that I was
making was that the Old Testament and
the New Testament
as I said before are records of an
evolving understanding among the people
of God and that because of that evolving
understanding they came to realize that
these things had no applicability for
all people for all time the uh idea that
the Old Testament is not applicable for
Christians is in the New Testament
itself that's actually a large
preoccupation of the New Testament that
they are free for the Christians are
free from the law and so you bring up
these Old Testament examples you're the
the big difficulty you have is that
nobody in the Christian world is
thinking this is marching orders for
today whereas people read the Quran
Unfortunately they do think that when it
says kill them wherever you find them
when you meet the unbelievers strike the
necks and so on and so on they do
believe that these things are marching
orders for today because the Quran does
not have these different
stages of development but this doesn't
mean in Christianity that just anything
goes in Catholicism and Orthodoxy you
have the apostolic succession and the
authority of the Bishops who can
authoritatively interpret the scriptures
and set the doctrines and those
doctrines have been consistent from the
beginning
excuse me you're interrupting once again
and I never interrupted you no I'm
asking a permission just a second okay
where and in in protestantism you also
have the uh
at least ostensibly a Fidelity to the
scripture so that you can't just say
anything goes and we're going to become
lgbtq now legitimately now there are
people who are doing this and they are
mostly in the Protestant purview because
they don't have this Authority that
establishes various understandings of
whether homosexuality is sinful or not
and so on and so they can reinterpret
these things and that is a big problem
nobody is interested in hiding any
problems but when you set up these straw
man arguments and say oh Spencer said
the Bible's fables and anything goes
you're just lying I never heard that
okay
I have a comment about statistics pure
Center say Islam gains about as many
comfort as it loses in the U.S so zero
at the end so even the twenty thousand
you can just cancel them another thing
um Elias bayones he said that 75 percent
of new Muslim converts they leave Islam
after that so not many 75 percent is a
huge number they go back because they
find usually they are fascinated with
Middle Eastern uh non-white religion and
uh yeah it's fascinating our brother is
wearing even the Moroccan jalaba he
likes it yeah oh it's our it's not
Muslim by the way it's Berber so you
just think because they're fascinated
with these things and they think that's
Islam when they start digging in oh I
didn't agree to killing apostates I
didn't know that Muhammad ordered that
well every entertained specifically
fight it okay Muslims stand for their
principles that's why he converted right
yeah I'm glad he converted to Islam so
take him uh just I want to say something
about uh Muslims converting to Islam
then you find out little by little
things that you don't you didn't agree
at the beginning every product comes
with a warranty except Islam doesn't
come with a warranty if you don't like
it your head is going to go so that's
why it's not an appealing religion and
and people would start rejecting it
after after defining these little
details inside I want to give them an
opportunity to respond and then we can
go to the next issue yeah I'd like to
respond because Robert brought up
Apostolic succession and claims that
these doctrines have been held you know
since the beginning of Jesus Jesus
proclaimed his message to the apostles
and they passed it on to early church
fathers and and then all the way down
the line and it's been this consistent
message throughout but on very core
doctrines which Daniel and I would
actually like to spend more time on on
what he called the 95 percent which is
actually monotheism unfortunately we
believe that Christians trinitarian
Christians are representing a veiled
form of polytheism and you claim that
this was the consistent message over
time well let's see what Justin Martyr
your own Saint says and he's in the
beginning of the second century he was
born in the year 100 in his famous
dialogue with trifo chapter 56 he says
this let's see if his theology is the
same as yours Robert
I shall attempt to persuade you since
you have understood the scriptures of
the truth of what I say that there is
and that there is said to be another God
and Lord subject to the maker of all
things who is also called an angel
because he announces to men whatsoever
the maker of all things above whom there
is no other God wishes to announce them
so Justin Martyr says that Jesus is a
second God is another God separate and
distinct and he is a lesser Divinity now
John bear who I'm sure you would know is
a famous uh Eastern Orthodox Authority
today he comments on this passage and he
says this as it is not God himself who
thus appeared and spoke with man the
word of God who did all of these things
for Justin quote another God and Lord
besides the maker of all who was also
called his Angel as he brings messages
from the maker of All Above whom there
is no other God then he says about this
passage the Divinity of Jesus Christ
another God is no longer that of the
father himself but subordinate to it a
lesser Divinity now that's just one
example Justin Martyr who you would
consider a saint you may even pray to
that the Eastern Orthodox pray today
dead Saints but the reality is that your
theology according to you on the Trinity
is actually more correct than the person
that you're praying to and I can go
through a whole more list of on key
doctrines like the doctrine of the
Incarnation the atonement and The
Trinity itself that the early church
authorities like Justin Martyr irenaeus
tertalian and on and on up until the 4th
Century never preached the doctrine of
the Trinity sir so when you make the
claim that your message has been
consistent without what we see in the
very Beginnings on the fundamental point
of who God is you did not have the same
Doctrine it took to get to the fort
century and that's why Christianity
because at its very beginning was very
comfortable with development oh who was
God is a man God is he God and man at
the same time so if you can have those
sorts of developments of course you can
have developments about how laws are
applied and whether or not we should be
celebrating lgbtq and all of that that's
your history sir not at all actually no
uh the difference is that when it comes
to lgbtq it's very clear that
homosexuality is immoral and that this
is the consistent teaching of all the
Christian groups up until quite recently
and so the ones that have changed that
have departed from the faith and you
cannot have a development that
contradicts what went before the
developments happen harmoniously at the
beginning of the church there was a
great deal of difficulty in
understanding exactly how it was that
God had become men and so you have
people trying to formulate it and Justin
Martyr tries to formulate it and he does
so erroneously you have some assumption
probably coming from Islam that the
Saints are infallible and actually
that's not the case and so you want to
quote me fathers of the church from
before nicaea all you want the fact is
that the Trinity was formulated at the
Council of nicaea in 325 and there isn't
anything that was taught by the
authorities in the church Justin Martyr
was a great saint but he was not one who
was
formulating the doctrine and in charged
with the responsibility to give us what
the teaching of the Christian faith is
The ecumenical council had that
Authority and they formulated it in this
way now does this mean that Justin
Martyr is a heretic no because he comes
before that this is a no because yeah he
was wrong yeah absolutely when he said
he's another God he was wrong there's
not there's only one God right
I know that the that Islam teaches that
all the everybody else is a polyphoon I
think you are well we're not and so
Justin Martyr was wrong
doesn't pose a problem for Christianity
it does because as you said the doctrine
of the Trinity doesn't come until the
fourth Century so why no there were
people teaching it from the beginning
listen as I said
you just said that the doctrine of the
Trinity came about and was established
at the doc at the Council of nicaea in
the fourth Century in the year 325. we
can talk about it another time because
we would actually like to talk about
theology we want to talk about that 95
so maybe we can do that another time but
the point is and I challenge you and I
will be happy to debate this another
time that in the first 300 years of the
church you do not have a single Church
Father whether it be Justin Martyr
irenaeus if you want to go to tertullian
although some people think he's just a
church writer down through the line up
until the 4th Century they did not teach
the doctrine of the Trinity and I will
defend that position Anytime Anyplace
okay because sure there were plenty of
church fathers who taught the Trinity
Ignatius of Antioch there are plenty of
before nicaea it didn't spring out of
nowhere basil the great writes about it
quite extensively and so it's you acting
like it was basil was when some people
made it was back well he comes after the
after the definition but I'm saying that
he explains so it's right so you think
that he's he's and he's one of the great
Saints and he's revered as also one who
form is is explaining and formulating
yeah exactly then I'd like to transition
to next time
that's why I said we went through that
part at the beginning we have a few
different things to go through so Villa
Mulvaney okay transgender Bud Light he
comes out he's going viral he costs Bud
Light you know Anheuser-Busch I don't
know 29 30 billion dollars it's a lot of
money cost him right
today has a change of heart okay goes to
sleep cannot sleep all night is praying
boom he wants to find god with the
religion of Christianity or
Muslim welcome Dylan to convert to
become a Muslim or a Christian would
Muslim welcome
yeah if he accepts that he cannot be
other than his biological sex
um you know that would be acceptable
like when you can when you become Muslim
it just requires saying the
testification of Faith there is no God
but God there is no God but Allah and
Muhammad is his final messenger then you
become Muslim and that wipes away
everything that you've done previously
you start with a completely clean slate
so everyone is welcome to become Muslim
and we invite everyone so even Adela
Mulvane it could be a Muslim yeah on
your end Dilla Mulvaney lived a
different kind of a life wants to become
a Christian change his life what
position does the Christian faith take
welcome yeah anybody can repent and and
become a Christian actually Christianity
is for Sinners people who admit their
sins and want to follow Jesus so he can
live a better life and um has his life
changed and that's what happened to me
and happens to Millions well in case
he's watching you have two choices
you want to go okay but I wanted to
clarify that for him I agree with Daniel
he needs to admit he's a guy great that
and I'm sure if he's going to go through
that he'll do it next question for you
enemy who is the enemy of Christians and
who is the enemy of Muslims who is the
enemy of Christian faith well the
classic answer is by uh Saint Paul that
we're not fighting against Earthly
Powers but against spiritual powers and
ultimately there's a spiritual aspect to
everything that that that that an
individual experiences in his life most
of the time they're not aware of it but
there are evil forces that try to lead
people to do evil Acts
yeah the the enemy uh is anyone who
threatens
um Freedom our freedom freedom of speech
freedom of religion and
um anyone who is trying to kill the ones
who are um different than his religion
or his thinking or his way of thinking
so
um any world view that will threaten my
freedom my uh way of life my way of
changing choose uh today to be a
Christian tomorrow a Jew tomorrow an
atheist uh anything that will threaten
that my choices and will force me just
to follow one way I will consider it an
enemy yeah so
um that's an interesting answer it seems
like his religion is secularism and not
the Christianity but when it comes to
Islam the biggest enemies Define in the
religion is number one Satan
um because he tempts people and takes
them off of the straight path
um then what's called Dunya which is
like the worldly life which is a
delusion the life to come the afterlife
that is the true reality
exactly so we have to be focused on God
and worshiping him and being on the
straight path and then also our desires
like lust that will cause us to commit
sins and then also our ego which was
called nephs the ego which tells us that
we're greater than God that we are more
important and that we are better than
others just because we are who we are
these are the four spiritual enemies of
humankind and then in terms of a worldly
perspective I would say liberal
secularism is the biggest enemy to all
traditional people Muslim Christian and
it is the world power today
affect did you have anything to say are
you going no I mean I just be
reiterating with that sounds good so so
here's here's a question I got for you
obviously in America everybody here
lives somewhere in America right we all
live in America yeah and there's a
reason why we're here we'd like to stay
here God willing make our life work make
things work and make it a place where we
can raise our kids have a family
actually I don't want to but you you
want to move out of here so you're
looking at other places really yeah have
you thought about some places Morocco oh
so you want to go where he is from yes
okay any reason for it what's your
reasoning my wife is from Morocco and
I've been there many times I've spent a
lot of time there and I enjoy it and I
want to uh I haven't had any children
yet and I am actually afraid about the
American society and the way it's going
especially over the past 10 years and I
don't want to raise my children here and
by the way to be fair a lot of parents
are also concerned about what's going on
in America today so good for you for
actually wanting to go there so here's
here's one part that's uh confused to me
um about three quarters of people of
Muslims voted for Hillary Clinton when
she ran for office about three quarters
this is not too long ago they voted for
that's Muslims right
today 74 of Muslims vote Democratic okay
when I look at values and principles
I'll give you top 10 issues for the 2024
ticket for Democrats and Republicans and
I kind of want to get your thoughts here
because this is an area where I feel
like you know
Muslims and Christians can actually be
unified in certain areas and if we do
it's going to be a formidable opponent
to go up against I'm sure they're not
going to like this so 10 most important
issues for Democrats in 2024 number one
climate change and environmental policy
number two Health Care three black lives
matter you know police reform things
like that four economic inequality five
voting rights six education then gun
control foreign policy National Security
labor rights and jobs okay the left is
more Pro lgbtq that being taught in
schools you know it's things that
they're open to the idea what's wrong
with that let them learn at an early age
etc etc on the right Republicans
economic policy and Taxation number one
number two conservative Judiciary okay
so Supreme Court having conservatives
being conservative you know Supreme
Court being conservative immigration
border security four second amendment
rights National Security and defense
social and cultural issues like abortion
religious freedom opposition to certain
aspects of the cultural worlds Wars Etc
race you know critical race Theory lgbtq
some of the focal points seven election
Integrity eight state rights and
federalism nine energy and environmental
policy in 10 being health care so Dems
Health Care number two Republicans ten
you know when I when I talk to a lot of
Muslims they the values and the way they
raise their kids and their families
I don't see any of it that would match
much of what the left is presenting why
do so many Muslims vote Democratic well
it happened after Bush it happened after
Bush basically uh pushed through this
Patriot Act which criminalized so many
Muslims just for their beliefs so many
imams were deported so many imams in
America American imams uh just based on
technicalities so many imams were put
under investigation put on watch list no
fly list which was expanded uh under
Obama actually and so that kind of
attack on the Muslim Community by the
Republicans really traumatized a lot of
the Muslim Community and I for many
years have been telling Muslims that
look we shouldn't just reflexively align
with the progressive left because their
tolerance and their acceptance of
Muslims is only skin deep when you
actually look at the policies and the
foreign policy of the Democrats like
Hillary of all people like Obama they
also have some very anti-muslim policies
both domestically and internationally
and we have to look beyond the niceties
like Joe Biden will come on and say you
know inshallah or Ramadan Mubarak and
maybe a republican won't do that so just
because he gives you that nicety you're
gonna like bow to that political party
that makes no sense we should not align
with one particular party we should
maintain our independence and others
should cater to the Muslim Community as
a voting Bloc
um as opposed to us giving our
allegiance to one side reflexively in
the way that has been done in the past
10 15 years
got it what would you say Jake no just
reiterate the same thing so I can give
them a chance Robert what are your
thoughts on this one here because to me
you know I look at the history and I
have the conversations and I'm always
you know surprised on what value from
the left I know there's a party where
it's like well the right there's more
pro-israel than the left is sometimes
the right is too much defensive of that
and the left is a little bit more open
to the idea but what would you say well
Israel does have something to do with it
and it is also a lot actually what
Daniel said some of it was actually true
that uh the uh policies of the Bush
Administration and some of the things
that still linger were so incredibly
wrong-headed and Muslims were quite
resentful in some cases with immense
justification at the same time also the
uh that I think this is the heart of the
matter the left is sold out to the idea
of racism and is obsessed with the idea
of race Islamic groups in the United
States particularly after 9 11 but
before that also like the Council on
American Islamic relations Muslim public
affairs Council and others they very
skillfully have portrayed any criticism
of Islam even opposition to Jihad
violence and Sharia oppression of women
and others as racism and bigotry and you
know Daniel actually said in some of his
debates that the uh you you criticize
the left's agenda and you get put on
hate lists and de-platformed well that's
actually happened to me because I spoke
the truth about Islam and the left does
not want that out they are completely
sold out to the idea that is the Islam
that Muslims are all of One race and
that they're non-white and that
consequently any opposition to Islam is
just racism and white supremacy and that
consequently they have to
stifle all criticism of Islam in all
opposition to Jihad and to fame and
destroy those who speak that criticism
and so the the Islamic groups love that
because Sharia actually criminalizes
criticism of Islam and it carries the
death penalty but yeah so they work into
your work is right that's a lot of Hui
your your site calls for investigation
of me like his sight he's called to
investigate me yeah well yeah do you
read your you do call for the death
penalty for Apostles articles on his
site dedicated just to me that I need to
be investigated because I don't agree
with LGBT I respond on his site the
thing about Robert Spencer and I'm glad
that he brought up this issue of racism
he is a racist like his sight anytime a
Muslim anywhere or any middle easterner
doesn't have to be a Jihadi or doesn't
have to be a Muslim even commits a crime
he puts it on his site and says oh
Jihadi Islamic Terror and he creates
this fear-mongering against immigrants
and imagine if you had a site dedicated
to whenever a Jewish person committed a
crime you say oh judaic violence and you
called your sight Jew watch or anytime a
black person committed a crime say oh
black watch this is Black Terror this is
black crime that's what he does to
Muslims and he's had a long career of
this he was involved in the same
counter-terror terrorism uh work with
the Republicans that he's now decrying
and saying oh yeah I disagree with that
you were a part of that effort you are
part of those administrations Daniel
you're like them you're lying again I
did I did advise the FBI when I was
invited I advised the FBI uh and
Military groups CIA a couple times
absolutely yes and that was mid-level
people who invited me who were trying to
change the point of view of the higher
ups and that's why I got in yeah that's
not like me that's terrorists and I
wrote I have this no you're lying these
three letter agencies on me because of
the kinds of work you're defined me and
you're lying and I need to am I not
mentioning your response yeah yeah there
are four articles there how many
articles are at Jihad watch about 80 000
going back 20 years Muslims there are
four that mention you and three of them
I didn't write so I'm not entirely
versed on everything they say mainstream
speakers
hate mongers who need to be investigated
and you approved did you not approve of
the Taliban I approve of many Muslim
governments do you approve of the
Taliban yes or no I do approve of the uh
okay yes I do so I attract Jesus excuse
me do you excuse me the Russian Orthodox
Church invading Ukraine no no you don't
denounce the Russian Orthodox yeah sure
okay your own church great the hierarchy
that's not my church it's perfect you're
not worth it I am Orthodox you have no
you see you have no understanding of
Christianity
you're lying again you set up these
straw man
Robert Spencer he said read everything
from Robert Spencer about Islam
he keeps multiplying those things and so
you have to allow for some time would
you accept with a site called Jew watch
answer that
it's not an analogy if my sights were
Muslim watch then yeah you would have a
point but it's not it's Jihad watch and
Jihad is people killing innocent people
terrorist activities flying the planes
into the buildings on 9 11 and so
Muslims excuse me you are interrupting
again and you were trying to make sure
that I can't answer this defamation
because you know that it's lies and you
want to make sure the truth doesn't get
out but the fact is that the uh site
tracks Jihad activity and it is a lie
that if a middle eastern or a Muslim
person commits a crime I put that on the
site I only put it on the site if there
is justification for the behavior in
Islamic texts and teachings you can that
Islam advocates for random killing of
people that's false you think plenty of
Islamic authorities
in the Bible that Justice
anytime you are interrupting yet again
excuse me there are plenty of Muslims
who will just for Muslim clerics who
justify the behavior and I give their
quotes
excuse me we can give them and as far as
brevit goes I knew this was going to
come up at some point it is a total lie
it was a total lie from the beginning
and I was ready for it so I actually
have what brevik actually said
the Muslims showed us that deadly shock
attacks are the only tool we have at the
moment which will guarantee that our
voice is heard that's on page 1351 of
his interview what he said about you
yeah read what he says about you he
quotes me and he quotes a lot of other
people he says I recommend everything
Robert Spencer has written on Islam did
he say that or not did you say that I
didn't say that okay now do you realize
what you're saying here what you're
getting yourself into here
you asked me a question no you asked me
a question you have the same ideology
brevik actually criticized me because I
would not call for violence
is this crazy man in Norway who killed
77 people at a youth camp they were not
Muslims as incidentally they were just
kids he was a nut he's he was a lunatic
and he wrote this 1300 page Manifesto
which is very aspect because for example
one of the reasons why I mentioned many
times in it is because in it is the
entirety of the script of a documentary
I was in in 2002 and I asked the
producer of the documentary how did this
lunatic get the transcript of the
documentary and he said I don't know Not
only was it never published but it was
never even made we never made a
transcript and this guy who speaks
broken English in half of his Manifesto
is suddenly perfectly transcribing over
100 page documentary in which I'm
mentioned multiple times and speak
multiple times it's very suspect and we
don't know if it was the who was behind
it it was with him I'm suggesting his
Manifesto was yeah you don't think
obviously the killing was real but I
think he might have written part of it
but he certainly had help he didn't
write no anyway the thing is is that he
said that the Muslims inspired him to do
violence he says that very clearly I
just gave you the quote if being quoted
by a bad person makes one evil then
if I am guilty because brevik quoted me
then the Quran is guilty because
terrorists I'm going to give Daniel a
chance to respond and then we have 70
minutes responding to everything else he
said yeah did you have a follow-up on so
the thing is my point wasn't that oh he
just cited Robert and that makes Robert
bad that wasn't my point my point was
that Robert shares the same ideology as
that terrorist that terrorists had the
view that immigrants are a problem
especially specifically Muslim
immigrants they cause a problem for
Western Society we need to stop
immigration this is a white supremacist
white replacement type of ideology which
Robert either shares or he he basically
facilitates with his site which takes
any time a middle eastern person commits
a crime and the best example he claims
that oh we check whether the person has
a Muslim background and has has some
kind of Muslim ideology this is false
just recently in June he there was a
Syrian who stabbed children in France
and Robert immediately posted up another
Muslim Jihadi attack on his Twitter his
site put up an article then it turns out
that this guy is a Syrian who's a
Christian his name is Abdul masir which
means a slave of the Messiah he's a
Christian and all the major news reports
BBC France 24 reported that this was a
Christian actually Robert doubled down
and said no no no this is a Muslim and
his sight continues to have an article
up that says this Christian is actually
a Muslim who stabbed children in a
playground this shows that it's a racist
this is a racist ideology that he's
promoting because it's not based on
ideology he just sees a middle eastern
name and says this is Islamic Terror and
that's just one recent example many
examples of this recently like there was
a stabbing in Brooklyn two more minutes
on on this okay because well then I have
to have a chance you have a you have a
go forward and respondent okay as far as
the guy in June goes he said he was
stabbing babies and he says praise be to
Jesus Christ now this is a obviously
he's somebody who's trying to imitate
whether he's a Muslim who is pretending
to be a Christian Isis has called for
Muslims to pretend to be Christians in
the west and Carry Out Terror attacks so
that's a possibility also there were
people who knew him who stepped forward
and there were stories about it in the
French press that said he was actually a
Muslim so I reported on these things and
I reported when he said he was a
Christian it's all there it was a
developing story and there were several
articles that we had about it but the
idea that there was some deception much
less racism that's just Daniel trying to
demonize let somebody who actually
agrees I agree with Daniel about it
that's what I like the funny thing about
it that's why you call for my
investigation I didn't like to go to the
next phase but I think you should be
yeah yeah there you go I'd like to go to
the next phase what do Christians and
Muslims have in common what do they have
in common well they would have disagree
but monotheism is certainly one thing
definitely not and uh there is in Islam
the uh appropriation of the uh biblical
prophets such that it's kind of Invasion
of the Body Snatchers Christianity I
mentioned the movie before they take
your personality and give you a
different one and so you have Abraham
you have Moses you have Jesus in the
Quran but they're completely different
figures from what they are in the Bible
Robert what do Christians Muslims
and Jews have in common in America what
values and principles do Muslims
Christians and Jews have in common
America yeah there's a general probably
in some aspects of sexual morality with
the exception of polygamy and sex
slavery of infidel women and some other
things like that wife beating but
otherwise you have the idea of the value
of marriage that's something certainly
that they have in common
what would you say what do Christian
Jews and Muslims have in common values
and principles in America
yeah we have we have shared values with
actual traditional Christians when it
comes to reform Christians they're
basically like Reza Aslan Christian
versions of Reza Aslan can you even call
them Christians with traditional
Christians that actually care about the
Bible and just don't don't call it a
book of fables we have values in
marriage you know preserving marriage
preserving Chastity modesty uh you know
opposing sexual immorality preserving
gender you know the concept of gender is
so important that's a shared value with
traditional Christians and traditional
Muslims the importance of the family
respecting parents respecting you know
raising children the right way raising
children to respect these values of
morality communities coming together
these are all shared values they're
Traditional Values do you think God
belief in God and and caring about God
do you think Society or or you know
again uh uh rip this apart as much as
you want brother Rasheed you can you
what I'm about to sit here right now you
can come in and fully disagree with what
I'm saying
do you think there is a uh uh you know
how we always talk about who are the
people of power like the real people of
power I'm not talking about like you
know Millionaires and billionaires or
presidents I'm talking people that are
really the people of power right do you
think they would like to keep uh
Christians Muslims and Jews uh
specifically Christians and Muslims
divided pinned against each other with
the fears of them potentially being
united or no that's a religious division
that there will never be a element of a
unification amongst Christians and uh uh
Muslims against a common enemy
I mean as somebody who studied Islam
Islam puts Christians and Jews as the
first enemies from the first from it
started Muhammad Muhammad Muhammad's uh
enemies they were Jews and Christians he
never mentioned Buddhists or Hindus or
any other religion he mentioned
basically Christians and Jews so that
Muslims inherited that that
um enmity from Muhammad until today if
you ask them who is the enemy they will
be the West if you go to Morocco for
example do a statistics it will be the
West especially America and Israel
because they represent Christians in
Jews so when when when the Quran says do
not take Jews and Christians as friends
do you think
what happened to Jews and Christians
through history was just random or was
based on Doctrine when the Quran says
like you have to fight the the
Christians and Jews until they submit
and they give the jizya do you think
that enmity started back then in the 7th
Century or just somebody caused it today
the enmity is inherited in the text in
the uh um he kicked the Jews and
Christians from the Arabic Peninsula and
Muhammad said
I will kick out Christians and Jews
until only Muslims are kept in the
Arabic Peninsula when he was dying in
his dead bed he said cursed be on Jews
and Christians because they took their
the graves of their prophets as as uh as
shrines so all these things
are embedded in Islam actually my book
uh the the ideology behind Islamic
terrorism the first chapter is in the
beginning it was hatred so the beginning
the root of terrorism is hating who are
not Muslims especially Jews and
Christians there is a huge hatred
actually in the Sunnah hating the
non-muslims is a must is a part of fate
you have to take only Believers as your
your close friends and close allies and
you have to hate disbelievers so this is
inherited if somebody want to follow
Islam by the letter he should take
Christians and Jews as enemies okay I'll
answer your request actually answer your
question uh the powers that be do they
want to divide Christians and Muslims
yes absolutely the powers that be
started this war on terror and they
started this attack on all religion and
tradition they started with Muslims and
they created this counter extremism
policy if you have certain beliefs as a
Muslim you believe that we should follow
the Quran as it was revealed follow the
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him then
you are an extremist and we have the
right to surveil you and detain you Etc
now they've moved that from Muslims to
Christians now Christians are coming
fire under Fire all the tactics that
were used against Muslims are now being
being used against Christians Christians
are being watched by the FBI you go to
protests like drag queen Story Hour at
the public library or at the school
board you're on a watch list by the FBI
so these were tactics that are used by
Muslims now they're being used against
traditional uh Christians and Robert
Spencer was a part of that whole
apparatus so yes the powers that be do
want to divide Muslims and Christians
because that way they can have an easier
time most people are attracted to
traditional religion most people hate
feminism most people hate LGBT most
people hate these new isms these
ideologies and they want to stick to
their traditions and values how to do
the powers that be want to conquer those
religions and values divide and conquer
so that definitely I'm on the same page
with you on that
yeah I only ask the question because you
know when when I started our own
insurance company this is the thing I
can use is because we attracted people
from all walks of life
it didn't matter who it was black
Hispanics Asians Christians
scientologists atheists Catholics
Hispanics Catholics
and we figured out the way to find
things that we had in common we have
disagreements
you know I just had a very nice friendly
debate with one of our top guys who's a
Muslim and we had a religious debate we
had a political debate but then we found
a bunch of things we agree with right
what what they valued what we value
right I don't think
um
you know eventually when and I know I'm
going to use this analogy because we
talked about the mob earlier and you
were talking about what happens when you
leave the mob and you're talking about
what happens when you leave the Muslim
fate eventually in New York the five mob
families came together and and they
unified together right and I'm not using
that analogy to say the similar things
here but I wonder what would happen if
we realized that what they're trying to
do to our kids none of us agree with
you know none of us agree with you know
the whole saying goes that somebody can
curse you out and you're like yeah
whatever hey Robert you're such an F in
this okay cool hey you know you're such
a half in this all right cool hey let me
tell you you know you're a loser cool
all right hey I'm gonna turn your kids
into teaching them about lgbtq at five
years old I'm sorry
what did you say I'm gonna do that in
Armenians like you go after the mother
no no we're not doing that you go after
Prophet Muhammad hey what are you
talking about what are you doing this is
not this is not okay with us I think you
know that's happening today and I don't
know if it's there right now
but I would be very uh interested in
finding ways to get more and more of
these communities together to talk we're
going to have differences we're going to
have philosophical differences when it
comes down to religion and Theology and
this and that of course and by the way
I'm not sitting here saying I agree with
some of the values and principles that
your Church offers or your faith offers
I can't live like that but I respect the
fact that you
respect it and you you're you know
devoted to it it it doesn't mean it's
something I want to do you know but at
the same time you're talking family
you're talking kids you're talking
certain things that we could agree on
Traditional Values that you're talking
about I can get behind that somebody may
watch us and they're Muslim they're
looking at Robert and Robert's obviously
the biggest antagonist on this
show today because
naturally you've written the most things
that's upset the most from the Muslim
side so you're gonna be a Target and
you've taken like a you know you've been
a good sport about it you know you've
sat here and you've heard and you've
given your position Jace come at you
very prepared I think Jake has done a
phenomenal job with his arguments that
he's had Daniel's been very uh
respectful uh brother Rasheed you have
been from your standpoint extremely
passionate about what you've done and to
be quite Frank your testimony is
probably the most powerful one out of
all of ours at this table thank you
because you've gone through it you went
through it you've seen the pain and at
the at the end though the audience I
hope gets to see again that we can sit
down have a conversation be respectful
everybody made their points there was no
limitations on what could one could say
and I think the real bigger enemy is not
gonna like us uh finding ways to unify I
just don't think they are and the role
I'm playing here is an element of my own
curiosity and long long-term finding
ways to you know fastest way to
eliminate an enemy is to turn him into
an ally I'm trying to find ways if we
can have some kind of a relationship and
unify folks from different sites and see
where this can go so having said that we
are at the end of the podcast at the end
of the discussion that we had appreciate
everybody's sportsmanship and being
respectful uh to one another for the
most part everybody was respectful Rob
let's make sure we put the links below
to everyone's book so everybody knows as
well as if you do have a YouTube channel
if you'd like to promote it so people
know to come and find you as well you
you do have one if you don't mind
sharing yours everybody if you can do
that and we'll wrap it up yeah my
YouTube channel is uh the Muslim
metaphysician so if you just typed it in
on YouTube or any social media platform
Twitter and whatever else you should be
able to find it there I mostly discuss
theology uh with Christians and atheists
so that's what I focus on and you can
find it there Daniel yeah I have the
Muslim skeptic Channel and also Muslim
skeptic talk com where we really debate
a lot of these issues are brought up we
didn't get a chance to get into detail
on some of these issues like minor
marriage quote-unquote wife beating Etc
so I really analyze these topics I
explain them in in a way that audiences
can understand and really appreciate the
Muslim perspective the Islamic
perspective
um so yeah I appreciate you Patrick for
doing this and having this kind of
conversation I think is really valuable
and I appreciate you for them yeah I
just I'd like to add that too because I
didn't get a chance to say that I think
that you've been very fair and and we
appreciate that also one more plug that
I can make sorry uh for Muhammad hijab
because Muhammad hijab you talk to him
and Eddie and they facilitated this so I
really hope that you have Muhammad hijab
on uh here because he's really a Muslim
amazing Muslim public intellectual and
he'd be you know you have a great
conversation inshallah I I would love to
have a a very influential uh gentleman
like Marvin hijab a one from the Jewish
community and one from the Christian
Community for all of us to have a
conversation to get I realized two hours
is not enough two and a half hours is
not enough I think that may be three
four hours but we'll figure something
out I know you have a channel I know
you're all over the place as well yeah I
actually uh I'm a little bit
uh lagging in terms of the videos I have
a YouTube channel Jihad watch video and
every Wednesday evening whenever we can
do it David wood and I do a show this
week in Jihad covering the latest news
uh but uh unfortunately I don't have a
whole lot else there I've been focusing
on writing books I have the critical
Quran and uh book the uh Empire of God
how the byzantines saved civilization a
history of the Roman Empire and the
Byzantine period that's coming in
November I'm also writing a new
biography of Mohammed Muhammad a
critical biography evaluating the
historical value of the various texts
I'm about halfway done with that that'll
be out next year fantastic thank you
brother Rasheed yeah I have a website
called brother rashid.com and also a
YouTube channel called The Burger sheet
TV and uh also have Twitter account you
can find me brother Rasheed Facebook
page have two two million followers on
Facebook page so you can find me there
and also my book is on Amazon if you
want to buy it the ideology behind
Islamic terrorism it's there what a
weird way
thank you so much Patrick for doing this
thank you very much anytime guys thank
you again for being respectful and being
a sport about it this was fantastic
hopefully in the future we'll do many
more of these again gang for those of
you that watched it I hope you
appreciated this Converse this
conversation as much as I did have a
wonderful weekend and we'll do this
again next week take care everybody bye
bye